the way i create a thriving environment
here at filtrus it's just about
letting people
be their own boss
not micromanage and feel this is like
almost second home to them
you can come in here and pretty much
share your ideas share your thoughts
have your opinions speak them freely
they're always welcome we make it what
we want to make it and we want to
preserve that because you want to have
this happy upbeat space sometimes it's
very difficult to
have that day in day out all day eight
hours a day um you know we have personal
stuff going on or you have work stuff
going on and and i think one of the ways
that i tell or i share with my
colleagues
is imagine a tree right outside the door
and you're having like a bad day you
know whatever it is and you just hang
your [ __ ] on the tree
before you walk through the door just
like to envision that and just like
leave your dirty laundry just hanging
outside the doors and when you are happy
or you're smiling or just like thinking
about good thoughts it comes across as
well for me i try to always have
background music playing on my radio on
my desk because that to me that's my
happy or i'll write smile on my paper on
my desk every day i write smile and i
put a happy face so if something happens
i'll look down and i'm like okay i'll
smile and those are things you know it's
just creating little things that are
gonna help you stay cheerful throughout
your day for me what makes filtrus
different than everywhere that i've
worked
is
obviously david his
support
with all his employees he literally
wants everybody that walks through that
door
be
successful and he genuinely feels that
in his heart and you can see that come
across and to me that's somebody who's
very passionate very caring and that's
very different than any other place that
i've ever worked i feel like i have been
in corporate america most of my life
you're just pretty much a number it's
really hard to get that personal
one-on-one feel from the owner let alone
the ceo for me it's gonna sound super
cliche
but it has
turned my whole life around and this is
the best way to describe it i feel like
i had been walking around life with my
eyes closed this place kind of opened my
eyes to this whole new world before i
came to work for filtrus it was you know
basically you go to work you do the
routine job you go home at the end of
the day not until did i come here did he
really push me
to really start thinking and focusing on
my own personal growth it's just been
like literally life-changing we all have
goals we all have
things that need to get done on the
daily in order to keep moving the
business forward but doesn't mean that
you can't enjoy
your day while you're accomplishing your
goals i help people have a voice by
pulling them aside and allowing them to
feel like they can express
the negative along with the positive if
they have something that didn't sit well
with them i try to let them know you can
come to me or you can go to anybody else
that you feel comfortable enough with
sharing that you would want to work here
at filtrus because it is still a small
company that's getting ready to
explode and not only that it's a place
that you can come and be part of
something that's
gonna be really big i've seen it already
and we're not even at scratching the
surface yet to have seen the company go
from not only four employees to 20 plus
employees now but seeing that little
building that looked like it could have
been gone the next day to being in this
building that we now own and seeing the
growth and the vision that david shared
with me from day one come to life
is super exciting my piece of advice to
a new employee is the sky's the limit
and really honestly it is the god honest
truth that
you can make this place what you want it
to be i've seen people go from the
warehouse to become senior lab techs
i've seen people go from the warehouse
to become sales reps there's no rules
here no traditional rules that you have
to have a degree or some kind of
background we will give you those
opportunities as long as you're willing
to work for them the sky's the limit
here
[Music]
you